So, stepping our materials up a little bit more, we can actually have parameter switches
to our materials as well.
So we can essentially get an either or scenario with a branch.
We can set the switch to choose between two different directions and whether to use maybe
this texture map or whether we use the base color and we can set a static switch to say
true or false.
We'll do a switch called use albedo texture question mark and if true we'll use albedo,
if false we'll use a base color.
So let's jump into the editor and do that and get that hooked in now.
So we'll find some empty space up here, we'll drag these to the side, we'll right click
add a switch parameter, so right click, switch parameter and we'll say use albedo texture
question mark and you'll see that you can also, if you didn't click the description
you can change it on the parameter name down here if you prefer.
I just type everything directly into the box there.
So you can also just select and then select again, not double click but select and select
again to edit the text.
So use albedo texture, if true well we want to come from the albedo texture so that makes
sense and if not we want to use a base color.
So I'm going to hold down three, left click, I'm going to right click on the node, I'm
going to convert to a parameter, I'm going to call this base color and then go into false
and let's just set a base color whilst we're here of maybe an off, just off white kind
of color just to make sure there's something there and then we can go directly into the
base color.
So now what we'll have is we'll have a parameter switch, if I save the material we've also
got a base color and a switch.
So when we go into our material instance now we'll actually see that we've got use albedo
texture and use base color.
Now the only two things I really want to change here which is technically one thing but let's
get this categorized back into our parameter group because it just looks way cleaner.
So let's jump back in here, we've still got our parameter group set up there so I'll use
parameter group.
So no parameter group for that one but we can definitely get a parameter group in with
So let's say albedo and we can sort that as number three which is underneath tint color
and then we can save it and therefore now we've got the static switch, use albedo texture,
we've got a base color there if we want to set a base color and whether we set the switch
to true or false gives us the optionality which is really really nice so it's like okay
you want to use this, that's base color, use albedo texture true, well now we can see the
other properties so not only does it categorize things it also tells you what options are
currently being used which is such a powerful feature of the material editor and really
really nice quality of life thing.